[Music]
hello everybody my name is Fletcher and
I work on the Chrome browser team has a
chrome browser specialist here with my
associate Nick yeah give yourself a
quick intro Iowan I'm Nick I work on
Google security in the IT department
great so what we're going to be covering
today in this session is we've gotten a
lot of feedback from our customers that
managing extensions at scale can tend to
be a painful process it could be a
little cumbersome and we hear you and
obviously there's people in the seats
today so most likely you guys may feel
similarly so what we're going to be
covering is we'll talk about at a high
level what extensions are why they
provide value in an enterprise as well
as some inherent risks that would be
included with having those present on
your end-users machines and then I'll
softball it over to my my pal Nick and
he'll talk a little bit more about how
Google manages extensions internally and
how we moved from a traditional way of
managing extensions through whitelists
and blacklists to a more enhanced
methodology that will detail there and
then we'll wrap everything up and we'll
talk about how you yourselves as
administrators can be able to roll this
out in your enterprise so let's get
started so why extensions what are
extensions obviously hopefully people
are moderately aware of what that is if
you're here today but if you're not
really it's just a software program
that's going to customize your Chrome
browser experience so users may use it
to add something as simple as a theme
have a change of how Chrome browser
works from a behavior perspective so
every time I open up a new tab I get
greeted with a beautiful kitten picture
or something along those lines as well
as productivity tools where I need to
join a web meeting or record my screen
so really those are the values that it
adds from
customization and productivity side but
nickel I'll throw it over to you tell me
a little bit more about what risks come
with extensions especially its scale in
an enterprise yeah so wall extensions
have a lot of productivity benefits
there are some issues because really
you're extending the browser and all of
its capabilities so extensions can you
introduce vulnerabilities if are not
properly coded or in case issues come up
later where third-party libraries
additionally depending on the
permissions they can access your cookies
which is not good because that's how you
authenticate to your websites they can
make requests as you as well as inject
JavaScript which can leak data if it's
not properly coded great thanks Vic so
some challenges that exist with managing
extensions there's kind of like three
things that really make it a painful
process first is limited visibility into
what extensions are installed so how
they've been installed where they're
installed as well as what rights or
permissions they require in order to run
and then being able to have a formal
vetting process I'll allow this
extension I won't allow this one it can
tend to be kind of confusing as well as
being able to have a management process
around that especially if you don't have
much visibility into what extensions are
present it's hard to determine what you
can or can't run as they might be
crucial to the end-users to in order to
get their job done so we have a dual
approach to protection the first side is
securing the source and securing the
source that's on us right that's on
Google to be able to make sure that
there is a safe and secure mechanism for
your users or your administrators to be
able to download and install extensions
on the other hand securing the endpoint
that's on the administrator right
through different policies and and we'll
talk more about not only the traditional
ways of managing extensions but this
enhanced methodology that you'll hear us
pretty much blathering around through
the whole session so let's talk about
our side the Google side which
is securing the source so we've had some
recent developments in the Chrome Web
Store on enhancing security so we've
removed inline installations so
extensions either need to be installed
directly from the Chrome Web Store or
pushed out via Force install by an
administrator as well as we've tightened
the review process so as developers
submit their extensions for approval our
algorithms have been tightened to
prevent malicious extensions being even
present on the web machines before they
get live or present on your end-users
machines as well as we've developed and
enhanced our platform through manifest
version 3 at a super super high level we
make it easier for developers to develop
extensions in a more secure way and
harder for developers to create it in a
less secure way so policy management's
this is as I said securing the endpoint
which is up to the administrator in
order to roll out these policies
traditionally this is all done through
whitelist these extensions are fine to
be installed blacklist these extensions
I never want to be installed on my
endpoints the problem with traditional
management as we'll talk throughout the
session is those whitelists and
blacklists tend to get pretty lengthy
and it can be a full-time job sometimes
in order to maintain those and actually
as as nick will highlight later on in
the session it's something that Google
traditionally internally used to manage
through those traditional whitelists and
blacklists
but we actually moved to an handsome
install which we'll we'll highlight and
you know provide you guys some tips and
tricks on how you guys can do it
yourselves but also it's really managing
by the behavior of the extension itself
so the permissions or what rights those
extensions need in order to run managing
just by that instead of by the extension
itself as well as blocking the action of
the extension on your most sensitive
websites so you
SURS are able to get the extensions that
they want but you're able to protect
your most sensitive sites from
extensions reading information for them
so we talked about kind of how I bought
I kind of foreshadowed I guess how
Google moved from a traditional
whitelist and blacklist method to an
enhanced methodology so I'm actually
gonna turn it over to Nick and he's
gonna talk about that journey for for
Google so go ahead and neck
thanks lecher so just a little fYI like
a lot of other companies we have a lot
of machines and I see a lot of machines
it's in the hundreds of thousands so
trying to make this work is something we
need to make sure it scales and rather
than white listing one or two extensions
we have about 60,000 extensions that our
employees actively use so going through
and individually looking at each one of
these isn't really something we can do
additionally our employees really like
developing new extensions for their
productivity we have around 7,000
extensions and not that's not just that
people have made it was some point but
these are actively used and installed on
people's machines so internally we
wanted to make sure there was something
that worked for us so the whitelist and
blacklist just up something wasn't
working so our philosophy we could have
just said let's just block everything or
let's just allow everything but we want
to make sure we allowed users to access
the extensions they need but we also
don't want that additional risk around
it so we wanted to have something that
still let people be product Evandro are
users because we have the responsibility
of protecting the data there are users
and trust with us so as Fletcher
mentioned earlier when we're using the
traditional blacklist and whitelist it
was kind of missing the mark there was
limitations are black lists we're
getting into the tens of thousands of
extensions long and that's just not
something that's that's doable that also
means that reviewing these tens of
thousands of extensions in the oil list
isn't really something we can do in
depth and it really doesn't help the
situation when an extension can go and
pull code from a different web site the
moment of loads
because there's really nobody to review
that additionally reviewing these means
you need someone to be able to go
through the JavaScript to figure out
what it's doing and when it's minified
and things like that that makes it
really hard to do so it wasn't really
giving us the security we needed so we
needed to come up with something
different we needed something that would
balance the productivity of the users so
they got to use the extensions they
wanted so they weren't waiting on us to
review an extension or whitelist it
along with the needs of security because
we need to protect our employees as well
as the data that our users entrust with
us so we have a new approach that
Fletcher talked about earlier this
enhanced mitigate the enhanced
management capability so we needed
something to scale to fit those tens of
thousands of extensions that increased
user productivity so they're not waiting
in hasta whitelist extensions as well as
mitigating the risk that came along with
it and we did this through the
introduction of managed by permission
and the brunt time most controls which
we'll talk about in a little bit so
before we talk about managing by
permission you need us to understand
what permissions really are so to limit
the risk to users extensions must
declare which sites they're gonna
interact with and as well as the risky
actions they may take and they do this
by requiring developers when they're
making the extension to declare
permissions and depending on what the
extension does some sites have site
permissions some of device permissions
some of both and it's the combination of
these two that cover most of the risky
actions that extend you can take so the
site permissions are the list of sites
that an extension may interact with and
the device permissions cover the risky
actions specific to the device and the
convergence of these to cover most of
the risk so when we talk about managed
by permission what this is actually
allowing you to do is block the
installation of an extension
specifically by the permissions it
declares so if you don't want an
extension to be able to view the screen
you could say the desktop capture from
blocked and then you wouldn't have to
look at the code of each extension
chrome would know at installation time
that extension has a desktop capture
permission additionally you can
configure extensions so if there is a
extension that you want to allow even
though it has particular permission you
can do that this also allows you to will
be called permission pinning so if you
have an extension you like you can list
the permissions it can use and if in the
future it updates and adds a new
permission it's instantly disabled on
all your users until it until you modify
it the policy so you don't have to worry
about extensions updating new
permissions without you knowing and
additionally you can list a custom
installation error message so when users
are blocked you can tell them where to
go to get help so this new method is
allowing you to bc4 from compromised
extensions because we rather than
worrying about what happens if something
updates or making sure that you've
reviewed the extension properly you're
looking at its behavior and you don't
have these long whitelists and
blacklists anymore you don't have to
worry about updates and you don't have
to vet each extension individually so
let's take a look at how this looks in
action great all right
so so thanks Nik yeah so we talked about
blocked by permission we talked about
how it works and the value that it
offers but let's let's see it in action
ok so in this scenario I have a user and
that user has customized their browser
experience they've installed this
extension that every time they open a
new tab they get presented with a super
awesome anime style studio ghibli
screenshot it's dynamic it looks great
myself as administrator really don't
care if they have this installed on
their machine if they want to animate it
up I'm totally cool with it
however and unlucky for this user this
particular extension uses a permission
or has a specific write that I've
determined it's no bueno
right so under this this is a screenshot
of the manifest for this extension and
I've highlighted in
I research that there's a certain
permission that I say no way is this
going to run on any of my devices and
that permission is the storage
permission quick sidenote there's not
really much wrong with the storage
permission it's not as various or
anything like that just for
demonstration purposes I picked it so
unfortunately for my user they're gonna
lose their super awesome Studio Ghibli
anime theme but lucky for me we're gonna
be able to secure the endpoint right
which is really kind of the goal
so there's actually three ways that you
can be able to do this via policy so the
first way is group policy and this is
the way that most enterprises are
managing Chrome browser so if you're not
managing group via group policy and you
have it in your environment I highly
recommend that you take a look and
download the Chrome Enterprise bundle it
includes some handy-dandy MSI's that you
can use to deploy out to your end-users
through your application deployment
method of choice as well as 300-plus
policies that you can be able to use to
maintain the look and feel manage
bookmarks security settings all that
stuff so if you have the super super
eagle-eyes you can see that it I am in
the extension management settings policy
but I'll zoom in for you so here I've
declared some I put a JSON string in
there and if you take a look at the left
where the I think stage left right left
I don't know there's a star and in the
star that denotes that this is a default
policy and what that means is that this
policy will apply to all extensions so
extensions that are already installed
will be disabled and any extensions that
are going to be installed will be
blocked just note that if the extension
is already present it'll just disable it
will not uninstall it and then I've
declared that the the actual blocked
permission and then storage is the
permission that I'm blocking so I talked
about there's three ways first way group
policy second
windows registry so if you don't
necessarily like to write JSON which
maybe there's some JSON gurus in the
audience I'm not sure I'm sure you can
get your kicks on the group policy part
but here is the the location where you
can be able to create a sub key under H
key local machine software policy Google
Chrome yeah I got them all okay and then
the extension settings and then there's
a sub key under there see that star
again so this is a default policy and
before you start pulling out your phones
and taking photos or note you're totally
fine yeah I was going to say that that
we actually have a white paper that's
coming out it's called managing
extensions in your enterprise that has
step-by-step instructions but you can
feel free to take your take your photo
whenever you want it's not NBA or
anything otherwise there would have been
like a million slides to say anyway um
we have a white paper that's coming out
which has step-by-step processes not
only to do this enhance method but also
the traditional way so maybe the enhance
method isn't right for you people like
options so if you want traditional
whitelists and blacklists it has step by
steps instructions too in order to do
that and that's actually was published
yesterday so at the end we'll have some
resources links and in a couple of days
or so it'll get pushed to your next app
you can go ahead and click on that so
I've created this key it actually
converts it to to JSON on the back end
which is nice and I talked about three
ways group policy Windows registry and
the last one is the Google admin console
or the new Chrome browser cloud
management feature that was just
released Phil was it today it was today
so hooray for you guys um and for us so
chrome brought us a cloud management if
you guys haven't heard of it it's
exciting new feature that's it's a free
feature and it's a great way to not only
be able to push policies from the cloud
but also gives you really enhanced view
into the extensions that are installed
and present on your users machines as I
talked way way long ago in the beginning
of the presentation that that's the pain
right being able to find out what
extensions are installed how they were
installed
and what permissions or rights they
require in order to run so you can
actually get all that information from
Chrome browser cloud management so I
highly recommend you take a look at it
and if you wanted to do this block by
permission you check a box right so like
I said not throwing anything up on the
JSON people that like to write JSON but
checking a box to me seems a little bit
easier at least it was easy to get the
screenshot so I've rolled this out
through one of my three policies group
policy Windows registry and the Google
admin console or the new Chrome browser
cloud management and let's see what
happens so sad face for my user I've
updated the policy and they get a
message and it says this has been
blocked as Nick highlighted before you
can customize this method this message
to say contact IT file a ticket through
your ITSM tool whatever you guys like so
you can see once it blocks I open up new
tabs and unfortunately for them the the
animated wallpaper is gone so pour one
out for this user so alright and it also
blocks the installation of new
extensions not just the currently
installed extensions as well exactly
so Nick tell us a little bit more about
runtime post sure so block by permission
is helpful but it's rather heavy-handed
way of going about things sometimes
because that means the user can't
actually use the extension so another
option is runtime host controls and what
this feature does is it lets you define
a list of websites the yukine's that are
sensitive and it lets the extension work
on all the sites except for the ones you
define as sensitive so when they started
do anything like reading cookies or
injecting JavaScript or modifying web
requests about a particular site the
browser will say what site are you
tempting to do this on and if it's one
of the listed sensitive sites then it'll
be blocked so the users still get to
install their extensions and it'll work
on all the other web sites just not your
websites which have your sensitive
customer data on them so the benefits is
the users can use the more extensions
you and you also get a protect your most
sensitive data you still don't have to
do anyway let's our black lists you
don't hunt for viewing
updates and you don't have to look at
the code of each extension you're simply
defined the list of sites you want to
protect and the combination of these two
is really what we rely on instead of the
way of some black lists so that's what
Google likes uses internally exactly
great
so all right so let's see it in action
so I have a user they have an extension
installed this extension toggles the
super cool and edgy dark mode they can
toggle it on they can toggle it off and
you know as I felt the same way about my
anime wallpaper user I feel the exact
same way about my dark mode user I do
not care if you have this extension
installed I have other things to worry
about so so yes if they want to ruin
their eyes in their parents basement
totally fine with me
right so however I've denoted that
Google Arts & Culture is my sensitive
site and I don't want any extension to
read any data off of my sensitive site
because it could have my IP it could
have PII or personal identifying
information for my users or my customers
so no extensions can run on that site so
let's talk about how you can do it so we
talked about three ways as you guessed
first one is group policy right I'm back
in my friendly nest which is the
extension management settings policy and
I have some JSON I'm using the star for
the default policy so this is gonna say
no extensions can run on my super-secret
public site Arts and Culture Google calm
as you can see there's some stars also
in the URL so there's some syntax that
you could put in here to make sure that
you can this will cover like HTTP HTTPS
as opposed you can put some stars in
there so that way you cover your like
sub pages so you're not just covering
your your landing page right so first
way group policy second way Windows
registry so you can see I'm kind of a
broken record here so it's the same sub
key and I've just added a string there
for run time block hosts and that value
is the same way so group policy what
registry big surprise last one is the
admin console or Chrome browser cloud
management so I've actually in the same
setting where I did the block by
permission I just right under there
where I checked storage before I have a
blocked URL section so I just put that
syntax in there and if I want to block
multiple sites I just had to enter put
one under the other and then I can be
able to block my most sensitive sites so
Group Policy Windows registry Google
admin console Chrome browser cloud
management your flavor of choice and
let's see the after effects so the user
goes the policies applied he goes to he
or she or they click on the toggle and
it does not affect my hyper sensitive
side of Google Arts and Culture however
it uses it's able to work just fine on
CNN travel so this is really what we're
trying to get to what every IT
administrators trying to get to is that
that kind of nirvana state that people
don't think exists but you know it's the
balance between users actually getting
what they want and being secured on the
endpoint so users they can still install
these extensions they can still run them
and get the customized experience or
those productivity tools but also we
have a dual layer of security to make
sure that users were protecting our most
sensitive sites and our endpoints at the
same time so Nick yeah so when we went
about rolling this out the first step
was really discovering what extensions
are out there and we needed to be able
to determine what permissions they use
so we didn't simply push out a change
and effect everyone and remove all their
extensions we need to know what the
impact was so this is something that
external customers can also use see BCM
for the Chrome browser cloud management
to be able to determine what extensions
you have as well as what permissions are
on those and from there you can figure
out which permissions you're gonna want
to block as well as which extensions
need an exception so the next step was
the planning that was the grandfathering
in the existing extensions so our users
didn't notice
so we grandfathered in all of our
existing extensions to just stop the
bleeding and then we kind of go from
there and Whittle that waitlist down so
we added that way list and remove the
unnecessary entries as time went on
after that we did that permission-based
blocking then we went back and we did
the run time host policies and we added
those in one by one just slowly making
sure that we didn't affect users and
from then on we just created any ongoing
for ongoing maintenance we created
acintya flow chart do we hand it to our
help desk that they can simply follow
whether or not to add an extension to
the white list based on what it's doing
what existing things are white listed
and from that we actually have a fairly
low queue it's it's about like a think
about 1/4 of an FTE currently that is
required to run that or less for a
company our size so it's definitely
something they can scale pretty well
great so obviously before what was the
before state I mean that obviously the
black list and white list was like yeah
a lot many tens of thousands of
extensions on a black list and even then
it wasn't really giving us the security
benefits we needed okay and I would
assume that your this less a fair person
like kind of leaning back and just
kicking it oh it's certainly a lot
better now you seem relaxed today so
that's good yeah yeah this has helped
look at us with banter this is great
okay
so so how do you guys apply this in your
enterprise right pretty similar right
and gosh I'm just gonna plug it again
Chrome browser cloud management right
being able to get visibility into the
extensions that are installed it's it's
really it's really the first step right
you need to find out where they're
installed who installed them what
permissions they require and you can
really get all this visibility in Chrome
browser cloud management so and it is
the first step in order to get to
enhanced extension management is is
auditing the extensions right because if
you don't know what's out there and what
different departments or geo locations
are using there could be some issues
when you just start rolling out policies
that may block extensions that are
crucial to your core applications right
so whether you use Chrome browser cloud
management which obviously I'm biased to
recommend but
I recommend you could also survey your
end users so you know call email however
you do it
pester them until they you know find
those kind of gold users that represent
each individual department or
geolocation and find out what extensions
they have installed and then take that
information and determine and build a
master list so this would be these are
the hosts that I know must be secured
that I need to protect so those would be
the runtime host ones that you would
block or yeah exactly I'm agreeing with
myself sorry and then these are the
permissions to restrict these are the
permissions I never want to run on any
of my enemy of my endpoints and then
review any existing process in a snit
kind of highlighted you know you might
find that your whitelist and blacklist
might be able to be shortened and you
might be able to let some extensions run
and be install that you normally
wouldn't have been able to let go in the
wild and then the rest of these steps
are really just kind of traditional
change management IT project management
you're gonna want to talk to the people
the department heads because you're
gonna be affecting their users and
you're gonna want to test it in a lab
and a pilot I know nobody in this room
text test this in production right
really reassuring they're okay
establish an operational process new
extensions are going to be rolling in
every day so you're gonna need to find a
way to vet in invade out usually by
looking at the manifest and seeing what
permissions are present or you can just
since you have your baseline of what
permissions you will our role in a while
you can just have the user install them
and if it gets blocked then they can
submit a ticket and then you can take a
look at at that point and then review
results survey your end-users roll up
production and phases to limit possible
collateral damage and here's how you can
get started right away so sign up for
Chrome browser cloud management get take
that first step to be able to see what
extensions are present on your end-users
machine so you can start building that
master list it's really crucial first
step to make sure that you're going to
be effective with this management style
test out the the extension man
Uman salad we're talking about today so
blocked by permission blocked by runtime
host and also take a look at some of the
latest documentation like I said we have
a white paper that's live now it'll be
it's actually linked it's the second
bullet point which is the extension
management white paper so I think that
this will be pushed to your guys's next
app via PDF and a day or so otherwise if
you I tried it today just to see how
well you know the the keywords was doing
and just type in extension management in
enterprise and it should come up
otherwise I need to argue with my
documentation person so the Help Center
feel free to submit you know take a look
there as well as at the very bottom the
browser specialist so that's the team
that I work on so if you guys want to
get some more information about how you
can manage Chrome browser in your
environment you want to talk about
making Chrome a default browser I
recommend it and feel free to email at
us at Chrome - Enterprise - browser -
specialists at google.com it just rolls
off the tongue it's really easy to
remember but like I said it'll be pushed
to your next app
[Music]